[Musique]
je m'appelle samuel boucher j'ai dix ans
et je suis 5e
je pratique le ski alpin depuis leur jeu
deux ans et la catch up les plus larges
7,1 c'est du sport sont impatients et
m'ont appris à me déplacer dans tout ce
que j'entreprends tous les jours nous
utilisons des des appareils consomment
beaucoup d'énergie
certaines méthodes d'exploitation de
l'énergie sont nuisibles pour
l'environnement
je vais vous parler d'une compagnie qui
a développé une technologie n'a
pratiquement pas d'impact négatif sur
l'environnement
cette compagnie et sur leur site et
[Applaudissements]
quand on commet une compagnie panneaux
solaires solar city est un fabricant de
voitures électriques tesla et devant
payer en impôts plus tard et les mosses
les visionnages le futur et l'énergie
renouvelable comme le seul à seul art
city va changer la planète pour le mieux
comme je vous ai dit tantôt le futur
c'est le seul à et la chaleur va
remplacer les énergies fossiles aux
énergies fossiles
c'est quoi mais les énergies fossiles et
des vieilles énergie on utilise depuis
longtemps et qu'on utilise encore de nos
jours et 6 energy la lpo rappelle le gaz
le pétrole le charbon et uranium ce qui
va contribuer à améliorer la peine et
puis de solarcity lé salut des
panonceaux large succès sur tout les
toits de toutes les mesures et la
planète
ensuite ils sont redit impôts en france
et un mur de puissance qu'ils font c'est
sympathique accumuler l'énergie captée
par vaux panonceau là où tu es seul et
vais vous expliquer comment cela ne
s'est pas moins le jour vaut pas non
cela ouvre ou tu sais la caténaire suel
il la voit ensuite au mur de puissance
qu'il a fait mal pour l'utiliser
maintenant ou plus tard comme par
exemple pour alimenter votre main
imaginez que c'est un coup aujourd'hui
là il fait super beau soleil et vous
panonceau là où tu es seul à kpn soleil
il a ensuite envoyé aux moeurs de
puissance il a accumulé lors la venue de
la nuit
il a vanté des arbres tombés et du
verglas est survenu plusieurs centaines
de poteaux électriques sont tombés
elle ville est plongée dans le noir pour
plusieurs semaines sur une maison et
lavaud cas vous avez pas les panneaux
solaires de tout cela avec un mur de
puissance qui ont accumulé l'énergie
captée par ou panneaux solaires pendant
le jour si vous avez touché là c'est à
dire des murs des hauts murs de
puissance avec des panneaux solaires ou
des cieux cela vous pourriez avoir
certains avantages comme vous ne seriez
plus obligés de payer pour aborder les
courses et il est relié au réseau
électrique et rioux se l'est sont
transformés en énergie
lorsqu'il entre en contact avec les
panonceaux la houle et user lorsque la
fille du maire de puy saint 70 et la
morale ondulant au delà c'est lui qui
envoyait o'shea aux prises et aux
branches et vos téléphones what a pas ou
autres besoins domestiques et tant qu'à
lui demeure depuis charles et lucas oil
energy ou lumière pour alimenter votre
maison en un et puis finalement si vous
produisez plus d'énergie que vous en
consommez et que vous êtes encore relié
au réseau électrique
vous pourriez en revendre à votre
fournisseur pour faire de l'argent c'est
comme si vous aviez une mini centrale
électrique chez vous ce qui va remplacer
les énergies fossiles mais bête
intention là toujours resté dans un coin
du mans c'est qui va diminuer les gaz a
fait ça et nous allons avoir une
meilleure à chaque être vivant
pour conclure je vous encourage à vous
par installer des panneaux solaires ou
de tuer solar sur le toit pour qu'on
puisse garder une belle planète ainsi en
santé encore des millions d'années merci
et passer une telle fin en soi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]